[موسيقى]
احنا قررنا نترك البلد بسبب الحرب بسبب كل
شي صار نحن بيتنا وضلينا
بالحرب سوريا خمس سنين فانا واختي قررنا
انه نحن نحاول نطلع على اوروبا
تجربه البحر اثرت علي بالجهه الرياضيه انه
صار عندي ثقه بنفسي اكبر وكنت بعرف انه
انا سباحه كرياضيه فيني اسبح وفيني اروح
على الشط بس انا واختي اخترنا انه احنا
نساعد بقيه العالم مو بس نساعد نفسنا
رياضه شيء كثير مهم لحتى اتعايش ولحتى
اتعود على كل شيء بالمانيا بلشت اسبح
وتعلمت اللغه بسبب السباحه وصار عندي
رفقات بسبب سباحه اكيد رياضه غيرت كثير
كان في اول فريق لاجئين بالعالم 2016
بالاولمبيادبح صار لي من وقت ما كان عمري
3 سنين وبتمرن بس ما كان موفر للفراس اللي
متوفره للسباحين الالمانيين كمثال كان صعب
اني انا اشرح
ليش انا تاهلت بس تحدي اني انا كمان بشكل
عام اني اقبل اني انا لاجئه وقبل انه هذا
الشيء ايجابي وماله سلبي كنت صغيره كان
عمري 17 سنه فشويه شوي تقبلت وفهمت انه
انا عندي صوت وعندي قوه وتمرنت كل حياتي
لحتى اوصل لهذا النقطه
[موسيقى]
ولما نحنا فتنا على
الافتتاح تبع الاولمبياد شفت كيف العالم
احترموا هالفريق كانت مصدر للامل لملايين
العالم فكانت هاي نقطه غيرت كتير بحياتي
[موسيقى]
تعليقي على هيك صوره
لازم السياسيين
والدول تغير
تغير قوانينها لانه اللاجئ ما عم يترك
بلده لانه فرصه العيش باوروبا او لانه هن
بدهم يصيروا اغنياء وهنن
نحن بنترك بلدنا لانه في حرب وما في امان
وبناخذ هيك رحل لانه ما عنا خيار تاني
لانه هدول الارواح هدول مو لعبه عم
يحاولوا يمرقوا بسبع او تمن بلدان
ويخاطروا بحياتهم حياتهم وحياه اهلهم بس
لحتى يكون عندهم اقل حقوق الانسان وهي انه
العيش بسلام
[موسيقى]
فلوس سباحه بصراحه كان فيلم كثير حلو نحن
نتفرجنا عليه كينا ضحكنا
حسينا بالفخر حسينا بالزعل بشكل عام بقول
80 ل 85 بالمئه كان كثير صح كل شي صار هل
السبعه كانت بس على بنتين هاي القصه كانت
على ملايين اللاجئين حول العالم وهيدي هذا
اهم نقطه
بصراحه انا دائما بفكر بالبنات بفكر لما
يحلموا دائما بنفكر نحن انه في حدود طريق
ما حيكون سهل بس انا دائما بقول ممكن
الواحد يفشل مره ومرتين وثلاثه ممكن 10
مرات بس اهم شيء تكونوا عم تعملي شي انت
عن جد من قلبك بتحبيه فهذا شيء كثير مهم
انه كل واحد عنده طموح ويعرف انه ممكن
يفشل اكثر من مره لحتى يوصل لحلمه
[موسيقى]